[Musica]
un caro saluto a tutta avete sentito
bene non ho detto né tutti ne tutte ho
usato un altro suono questo suono ha un
nome si chiama schwer alla tedesca o
sheva e è il suono che corrisponde alla
vocale media per eccellenza sta seduta
esattamente nel mezzo del quadrilatero
delle vocali lì quando io pronuncio
tutte le altre vocali
ho bisogno di deformare la bocca in
qualche modo a e io lo smak sta nel
mezzo e si fa con la bocca riposo tutte
ma è difficile e lo stesso suono che
facciamo qua ma non sappiamo rispondere
alla domanda uguale
quello lì ricordatevelo da dove viene
perché mi sono messa a usare questo
suono strano lo sci ma che è
rappresentato da una piccola è capovolta
è di genere maschile intanto non
chiamatelo large va perché si offende è
un simbolo dell'alfabeto fonetico
internazionale o ipa international
fonetica alphabet è un alfabeto molto
particolare che i linguisti usano per
riuscire a disegnare a mettere per
iscritto
tutti i suoni di tutte le lingue parlate
dagli esseri umani al mondo quindi un
linguista conoscendoli pa riesce a
capire come si pronuncia qualsiasi
parola
quindi è un alfabeto potentissimo se ci
pensate ci fa il nome viene dal tedesco
cioè noi usiamo il termine tedesco e il
tedesco lo prende dall'ebraico shabwa in
ebraico vuol dire nulla
niente zero perché appunto è un suono
che si fa con la bocca a riposo
quand'è che è venuto in mente alle
persone di usare lo smart c'è un
problema endemico così per così dire
strutturale della lingua italiana che è
come rivolgersi a una moltitudine vista
normalmente diremmo
buonasera a tutti e tutti però da almeno
4 o 5 anni di più negli ultimi si è
iniziato a pensare a un'altra questione
se quella moltitudine mista contiene
anche persone non binarie cioè che non
si riconoscono nel binari smo di genere
come faccio
buonasera a tutti e tutte o care tutte
cari tutti non funziona più
e allora in molti contesti lgbt qua plus
collettivi femministi dove insomma si fa
una sperimentazione più attenta sulla
lingua sia iniziato a usare tutta una
serie di simboli paesi dalla tastiera da
quelli che abbiamo a disposizione
l'asterisco la chiocciola l'apostrofo
l'aics il trattino basso la barra la
carica route to ciao a tutti perfino la
ypsilon è anche la lettera che a metà
fra la è lei che ha fatto latino conosce
bene ma che sono le identità non binarie
le identità non binarie sono identità di
genere che non corrispondono
completamente al genere maschile e al
genere femminile
quindi sono persone che non si
riconoscono in nessuno dei due generi
stiamo parlando di meno dell'un per
cento della popolazione
questo è vero però se noi pensiamo in
un'ottica identitaria nelle quali le
parole contano e contano per auto
definirsi
voi capite che questo è un problema ci
sono delle persone che non sanno che
genera usare per riferirsi a se stesse
se noi adottiamo un ottica inclusiva non
possiamo escludere dal conto delle
persone che ci interessano quell'uno per
cento che non si riconosce nei generi
se noi adottiamo un ottica inclusiva non
ci sono persone di serie a e persone di
serie b quindi il fatto che si stia
parlando di meno dell'un per cento della
popolazione non ci deve toccare e però
io ho un problema anche con la parola
inclusività e non sono l'unica perché
inclusività da vocabolario vuol dire
capacità di includere di accogliere di
non discriminare però se ci pensate
inclusività ricrea una differenza una
divergenza una disuguaglianza fra chi
viene incluso e che include cioè ricrea
una società norma gente in cui i normali
includono i divergenti e divergenti
vengono inclusi e soprattutto su disco
in all inclusione cioè la parola
inclusività toglie agenti vita ai
divergenti per questo mio amico studioso
di autismo e di inclusività autistico
pure lui fabrizio acanfora dice perché
piuttosto non usiamo
convivenza delle differenze delle non
con le perché delle implica che siamo
tutti differenti e che dobbiamo imparare
a convivere con le differenze reciproche
e in questa ottica nella convivenza
delle differenze tutte le università
contano perché appunto tutti siamo
differenti anche quelli un per cento che
non si riconosce nel b dal ismo di
genere non siamo i soli che si stanno
interrogando su queste cose nel mondo ci
sono diversi esperimenti di lingua di
convivenza delle differenze in inglese
hanno preso da un po di tempo a usare il
singolo dei per riferirsi a persone
appunto che non sono né gli nesci in
america latina troverete la ics e quindi
la thinks ma non solo in spagnolo in
spagna viene usata la roba la chiocciola
oppure il plurale inetto des infine lo
svedese certo una lingua dinamica più
giovane meno storicizzata ha incluso ha
inventato addirittura un pronome
inclusiva un nuovo en perché lo show va
allora intanto si può pronunciare
laddove per esempio l'asterisco no non
non è mai stato usato per nessun genere
mentre al contrario la in molti dialetti
italiani è una marca di maschile quindi
tutto a me sembra un super maschile è un
suono indistinto per un genere
indistinto anche semanticamente funziona
poi se voi prendete in mano un testo con
lo sci ma vi accorgerete che la sua
quasi non si nota
forse per questo che piace così tanto
forse per questo che fa così paura però
un punto a suo favore
e anche che è esotico in qualche modo lo
sci fi visto come più hipster rispetto
alla steri scola barra la chiocciola e
tutto il resto
e allora perché non lo sa ma intanto è
un suono alieno al l'inventario phone
ematico dell'italiano standard anche se
è presente in molti dialetti soprattutto
del sud del meridione è difficile da
usare perché non c'è su molte tastiere
di computer e neanche di cellulari anche
se sui cellulari stanno iniziando a
inserirlo fra le opzioni della
e abili st questa la cosa più grave crea
un problema sia nei confronti dei
dislessici sia nei confronti degli
anziani quindi anche agi sta perché
rende tutto più difficile
e poi invasivo stiamo parlando di
modificare la morfologia dell'italiana
il modo in cui decliniamo le parole non
è facile come creare nuovi sostantivi è
qualcosa la modifica la morfologia che
potrà accadere solo se una gran parte
delle persone lo vorrà fare
eppure nonostante tutte le difficoltà le
persone stanno usando lo sva in editoria
c'è una casa editrice che sta stampando
i suoi saggi con lo sci ma invece del
plurale maschile sovrà esteso nei
fumetti
abbiamo avuto nel novembre 2000 eventi
si o alias simone albrigi che aveva
fatto un poster per lucca comics
conosceva benvenuta e recentemente l'ha
usato anche 0 calcare in un suo graphic
novel uscito su internazionale
ogni tanto la cima compare nella
pubblicità e infine una notizia che ha
creato grande scandalo ma anche molto
interesse
una amministrazione locale di
castelfranco emilia ha deciso di usare
la schwan nelle sue comunicazioni social
solo social ovviamente quindi a chi
avesse dei dubbi
niente paura la lingua non si cambia
tavolino non c'è nessuna elite che vuole
stravolgere l'italiano a meno che non
crediate anche voi al complotto dei
transgender
spero di no nessuno vuole e può imporre
nulla
anche quando ci hanno provato in passato
in italia le cose sono andate abbastanza
a ramengo le cose non hanno funzionato
e allora di cosa stiamo parlando stiamo
parlando di una cosa meravigliosa
sperimentazione la lingua ci permette di
sperimentare ci permette di cercare le
formule che funzionano meglio per noi
stessi per definirci e io credo che
all'interno di una società che vada
nella direzione di una convivenza delle
differenze non ci debba essere
assolutamente nessuno che non può
abitare con agio la propria lingua
credo che questo rientri fra i diritti
di ogni persona sentirsi a proprio agio
usando la propria lingua
e non svegliarsi la mattina con la
sensazione di non so come riferirmi a me
stessa
ecco perché la schwan andate fuori
guardate dove lo troverete è un
esperimento non dovete averne paura
magari aiuterà le prossime generazioni a
trovare una soluzione migliore di questa
che diciamo così a soprattutto la
valenza di avere evidenziata una
questione che prima alla maggior parte
delle persone era assolutamente aliena
grazie